look you want to know what's crazy about
the whole situation she came up with
this rule okay what's that I can't work
with any female artists
and she won't work with any mail artists
is that the robot well it was right she
came up with this rule did you come up
with this rule
after the fact that something had
happened
it's not the best rule it's a terrible
Rule
now
it works
the same thing so what you even talking
to them for if you came up with this
weird-ass rule
y'all gotta get rid of that rule man
I got paid 40 000 from a female to do a
song she talking about give it back
because he was I said
you we was beat for that weekend where
he didn't take me to the session he
didn't take me to the video shoot none
of that he was being weird so he's being
weird with a feature it made me like
what that's that's what what happened we
was beefing you didn't invite me nowhere
when you was doing it right and then he
was making like you doing something way
more important than hanging out with me
like it was weird what does that have to
do yeah it's like certain things he do
it get out of my skin shut the [__] up
what I'd like to say it's really good to
see both of y'all without a bottle of
Hennessy around that's great
do you feel like Christian like you guys
were like becoming a little dependent on
the bottle for a while it looks like
everywhere I would see y'all there'd be
a [__] no I just like the bottom you
just like Hennessy yeah a little too
much no I'm not dealing with him no
she's like I need it [__]